ich hab euch mal auf instagram ein foto
von meinem schoko baiser gepostet und es
hat euch so gut gefallen dass ich euch
heute ist mal das rezept vorstellen
möchte und zwar ist im prinzip einfach
nur wow teig aus dem i done so kleine
schoko pcs macht die richtig gut
schmecken
außen sind sie schön knusprig sind so
richtig schön schokoladig und weich und
ich werde jetzt nicht nur zeigen wie man
die kleinen schoko bis es macht sondern
ihr könnt auch mit diesem budget tag
später retorte machen und zwar nennt man
das das zeige ich euch jetzt aber im
anschluss so erst einmal zeige ich euch
die zutaten für die kleinen yogis und
zeigen wie es weitergeht
und zwar braucht ihr dafür fünf eiweiß
eine prise salz zweieinhalb esslöffel
kakaopulver das sind etwa 30 gramm
dann braucht ihr 250 gramm zucker und
125 gramm schokostreusel das sind so
schoko plättchen schokoraspeln ganz egal
was ihr möchtet im prinzip könnt ihr das
wenn ihr zum beispiel ein eiweiß übrig
habt ganz gut im rechnen und zwar könnt
ihr da rechnen kann weiß braucht ihr 50
gramm zucker und 25 kostet und
kakaopulver eltern pro ein weiß etwa so
fünf gramm also einen teelöffel jetzt
zeige ich euch wie man daraus diese
masse macht und wie man dann die show pt
herstellt und ganz wichtig ist doch dass
ihr hier kakaopulver nimmt also dieses
back kakao und nicht dieses fertige
körper pulver zum trinken weil im cover
pulver eben noch zucker mit drillisch
dass ganz viele angereicherten
mineralstoffe und vitamine mit drin und
wir brauchen aber nur das kakaopulver
gegen dieses ganz normale kakaopulver
zuerst gebt ihr jetzt das eiweiß in oslo
schulen schlüssel können dann natürlich
auch in mit einem handrührgerät machen
da kommt jetzt das salz mit dazu das
bewirkt dass die eiweiß struktur
schneller zerstört wird
und es wird jetzt auf höchster stufe
schön steif geschlagen und dann gebe ich
erst wenn's steif geschlagen ist den
zucker mit dazu
und wenn ihr das dann schön steif
geschlagen habt das erkennt ihr daran
dass messerschnitt eben sichtbarkeit und
die spitzen schön stehen bleiben und
wenn ihr es habt kommt jetzt dieses
kakaopulver rein und wird einmal
angerührt
der grund was der hauptstadt zu diesen
kaka oben guck mal wie schön stressig
habe ich vor allem einer maschine
hingekriegt
dann gebt ihr da die gsoa streusel mit
rein und die werden dann sonst wären die
untergehoben mit nehmt euch am besten
zwei teelöffel und nehmt euch damit die
masse heraus und setzt sie auf eine back
folie oder auf dem backpapier so kleine
häufchen mit ein bisschen abstand weil
die noch ein bisschen aufheben könnte
natürlich auch mit einem spritzbeutel
machen geht auch stolperdraht das schöne
häufchen
ich zeige mich jetzt noch wie ich das
mit einem spritzbeutel machen und zwar
kennt ihr das sind vielleicht schauen
dass ich schon hin spritzbeutel ständer
da habe ich einen einweg spritzbeutel
mit loch thüle rhein gegeben und so kann
man eben gut freihändig dann arbeiten
weil ich so den spitz heute eben nicht
heben muss und ich kann dann auch mal
abstellen wenn ich koste es anderes
machen muss hier vorne habe ich in
diesem einwegspritze eine lok schule
eine große und habe diesen antrag für
große loch türen und alle produkte die
hier bei mir sehe ich verlege ich euch
in der infobox
die infobox ist hier unten unter dem
video dasteht info da müsste drauf
klicken und auf mehr klicken
weil man immer nur einen ganz kleinen
ausschnitt davon sieht und da stehen
dann alle informationen rund ums video
auch das rezept und das könnte dann
anklicken und eben alle produkte mit dem
spitz freundin habt ihr einfach den
vorteil dass sie das jetzt hier ansetzen
könnte und könnt die häufchen so groß
machen wir jedes haben möchtet und es
geht einfach auch viel schneller und da
empfehle ich euch eben eine große loch
schüler wegen diesen schokostückchen
jetzt merke ich hier dass hier auch die
stoffe schokostückchen drin hängen
das heißt ich brauche noch eine größere
noch thüle und das ist der vorteil an
diesem system das sich während dem
spritzen einfach das austauschen kann
weil ja die luft schüler später
eingesteckt wird
man könnte einfach eine andere schüler
drauf setzen nämlich einstein schule da
dürften nämlich die schokostückchen
durchgehen und stand können da ganz
einfach weiter spritzen
ihr könnt aber natürlich auch mit dem
ein weg sprich freude ganz ohne töne
machen dann könnte da vorne einfach ein
stück abschneiden
gutes aus der öffnung heraus treffen
jetzt kann ich das einfach wenn ich das
aus der hand legen muss ihr bein stellen
und dann aber auch gar nichts diese sehr
häufig hinkommen jetzt bei 130 grad ober
und unterhitze für etwa 25 minuten in
den ofen da trocknen sie von außen
leicht an und ihnen bleiben sie richtig
schön saftig und bei nächster ofen immer
vorgeheizt es ist einfach viel besser
weil euch dann die sachen nicht
verlaufen
die teige die ihre reinsteckt die
bekommen wir quasi so einen leichten
schock und stocken dann schon mal
angenehm in den ofen gibt und wenn ihr
das nicht macht kann es eben passieren
dass ich sachen verlaufen und eben nicht
das richtige ergebnis erzählt manchmal
kommt nämlich vor dass mich leute an
schreiben also 12 mal war das jetzt und
die gesagt haben dass ihnen die rezepte
nicht gelingen die ich mache habe ich
ihn gewundert und wieso das nicht
gelingt habe deine fragt was sie genau
gemacht haben und im endeffekt war es
dann wirklich so dass er einfach den
ofen nie vorheizen und es dann eben bei
umluft machen statt bei ober und
unterhitze und das gab dann eben nicht
als ihr müsst euch da schon dran halten
die temperatur kann es schon sein dass
noch plus minus 20 grad geht und auch
wegen der backzeit aber der ofen muss
auf jeden fall immer vorgeheizt sein
damit es eben alles schön klappt nach 25
minuten sind dann meine these schönen
durch getrocknet und dann könnte das sie
einfach rausnehmen und auf ein auskühlen
gitter geben damit sie eben von oben und
von unten abkühlen können und stadtleben
schneller kalt sind
da gebe ich dir jetzt einfach drauf
insgesamt habe ich jetzt freifläche
vollgespritzt das heißt es sind so etwa
60 baiser stückchen die er daraus
bekommt je nach größe eben und das kann
ich euch jetzt mal zeigen das sieht man
auch in warmen zustand schon super dass
der aussenraum schön trocken sind und
ihnen schön feucht und ich bin natürlich
auch dass die bahn richtig gut schmecken
was sie dann nämlich noch richtig freuen
wenn also die schokolade die pc könnt
ihr dann in einer schachtel aufbewahren
ich hatte meine letzten hier drin
aufbewahrt
da werden sie dann natürlich auch von
tag zu tag trocken ist der sohn des
emirs das hörer auch richtig dass sie
dann auch schön hart werden weil sie
eben gut durchgetrocknet sind und jetzt
möchte ich euch noch zeigen wie er aus
dem teig oder aus dieser bc was eben
noch ein paar machen könnt und zwar ist
ein australisches oder neuseeländisches
rezept die australier neuseeländer die
streiten sich darum weiter eine sagt ich
hab davon unter anderem erich gefunden
und das ist jetzt so eine abgewandelte
version uns war es im prinzip so eine
torte in der ihr ebenso eine wc massa
als grund teig habt das wird dann eben
gebacken und getrocknet und außen ist es
daneben auch schön knusprig und innen
richtig sowieso eine marshmallows schön
feucht dann kommt da geschlagene sahne
obendrauf und daneben früchte der saison
und es wird aber jetzt leicht
abgewandelt und zwar braucht ihr dazu
keine schokostückchen ich sage jetzt
einfach noch mal sicherheitshalber die
ganzen zutaten und zwar habe ich hier
auch 51 250 gramm zucker die prise salz
und die zweieinhalb esslöffel
kakaopulver und hier nehme ich jetzt
einfach noch ein teelöffel speisestärke
das kennt ihr ja auch von meinem 12
stand örtchen video bei meiner zweck
stellt heute mit dieser bvb war es
nämlich auch so wenn man da etwas
stärker nimmt dann wird dieser bc eben
auch richtig bösartig also richtig schön
knusprig außen rum und innen feucht bei
den kleinen bissig stückchen braucht es
nicht unbedingt könnte das natürlich
auch nehmen
aber hier bei diesem rezept jetzt könnte
auch den kakao weglassen dann strich
dieses original meuselwitz oder
australische rezept oder eben so wie
jetzt bei mir
diese operation und ich möchte die
schoko version machen und werde es
einfach den pc wieder gleich so bereiten
so wir vorhin im video und werde dann
eben die speisestärke nochmal unterheben
und zeige mich dann wie es weitergeht
und auch hier steht ganz wichtig dass
diese baiser masse wieder ganz fest ist
also so wie hier nichts runter und jetzt
braucht ihren backpapier und zeichnet
euch daran kreis drauf oder ihr könnt es
auch so machen dass ihr so wie bei mir
seine silikon bachmann zunehmend dass
ich meine normale ist silikon mantel die
ich eben auch zum ausrollen von von dort
und so weiter benutzt
und da sind diese kreise schon
vorgezeichnet und da steht zum beispiel
auch welcher durchmesser und jetzt nehmt
ihr euch diese masse und gibt die darauf
dass der kuchen sollte so etwa drei
zentimeter drauf gestrichen werden und
dann streichelt es erstmal so ganz groß
ich möchte es mal mit den 26 zentimetern
das hier müsste jetzt richtig schön
sorgfältig machen damit es schön
aussieht später und abschließend den
rand habe ich jetzt heben so matthai
karte sauber gemacht
dann habt ihr hier außen dann richtig
schöne brand so in etwa könnte das
aussehen wenn ihr das auch schafft was
ihr machen wollte und zwar könnt ihr
euch dann entweder auf die rückseite den
kreis zeichnet und dann hier eben diese
masse drauf streichen oder ihr macht
sich einfach und legt so eine silikon
matte darunter ich habe dir eben auch
nur den ruhestand könne die das
backpapier einfach drauf legen und
diesen teigmasse einfach darauf
verteilen und schöneben platzieren sowie
auf der seele kunden mathe auch und beim
streichen müsste wirklich darauf achten
dass sie das nicht zu groß macht weil es
einfach noch beim backen und beim
trocknen eben ihnen die breite
auseinander geht
und dann kommt es jetzt in den ofen in
den vorgeheizten bei etwa 180 grad und
sobald der kuchen also diese these so
etwa zehn minuten drin steht und leicht
anfängt braun zu werden werde ich das
ganze runterschalten auf 130 und dann
musste der b6 so etwas 60 bis 80 minuten
offen bleiben bei 130 grad und dann wird
der ofen ausgeschaltet dann wird die
ofentür geöffnet und dann werde ich das
ganze einfach abkühlen lassen im ofen
wenn wir jetzt sehen dass die baiser
masse richtig schön hart geworden ist
und so werde ich sie im backofen
komplett auskühlen lassen
mein baby schönen durchgetrocknet ich
muss euch jetzt allerdings so eine
kleine verbesserung sagen und zwar
klappt es backen auf das silikon mache
nicht weil einfach der pc dann zu feucht
bleibt weil er von unten der pc karte
trocknen kann
ich hätte eigentlich auch schon viel
früher dran denke solle also benutzt
bietet die zweite methode dass ihr
backpapier auf eure silikon masse legt
so zum abpausen oder mal eben einen
kreis auf europas papier und macht diese
pc masse bitte auf backpapier ich habe
nämlich das ganze jetzt noch mal machen
müssen und ob es daneben noch mal im
backofen gebacken
mein pc war richtig schön perfekt bis
die sanierung mit ihrem finger haben und
da sind wir ein gedrückt hat das sieht
jetzt hier
was aber das schlimme an der ybbs gleich
ne sahnehaube drauf kommt aber da war so
schön
da könnt ihr euch mal zeigen dass der bc
außen rum so richtig schön trocken ist
und das ist eigentlich so dass positiv
wetter zwar kann man sehen dass es so
eine richtige zone marshmallow artige
konsistenz hat also wie ihr seht also
noch schön feucht und so sollte es auch
sein ich es also nicht schlimm wenn er
euch kaputt geht da war schön arbeiter
wird jetzt auch gleich wieder schön
gemacht und jetzt habe ich zum fertig
stellen hier zwei welcher sagen mit
jeweils 200 gramm also insgesamt 400
habt zwei esslöffeln vanillezucker ihr
könnt auch ganz gern noch drei teelöffel
san abnehmen muss aber nicht sein
dadurch bleibt die sahne länger steif
aber wie gesagt es muss nicht und dann
kommt da noch ein paar früchte drauf und
da empfehle ich euch einfach ein paar
saure früchte zu nehmen weil der pc
schon süß ist die sahne machen wir nicht
so süß und daneben der kontrast mit
sauren böden oder sauren früchten der
super ich habe jetzt jedenfalls alles
gekauft wird natürlich alles importiert
um die auszeit und hier habe ich ein
paar tiefkühlen werden da wollte ich
einfach keine frischen aus dem ausland
nehmen sondern auch einfach tiefgekühlt
werden genommen
und da könnte je nach saison einfach
werden nehmen dies gerade hat und wie
gesagt so sollten sie sein damit eben
nicht zu süß wird die sache werde ich
jetzt in der kitchen aid steif schlagen
und zeigt euch an wie ich das mache ich
gebe jetzt einfach die sahne in die
küchenmaschine und da kommt jetzt der
spritzschutz drauf denn bei fahne
spritzt das ganze immer sehr extrem
jetzt lasse ich das kurz anrufen gibt
dann den vanillezucker mit dazu und dann
kommt noch dass sein apartment dazu und
danach sieht es richtig schön steif
schlagen und dann müsste bei der kitsch
nicht aufpassen dass sie diese nicht
über schlagt
dann müsste doch immer mal wieder gucken
ob sie schon steif ist also die brauchen
noch ein bisschen ganz kurz
und so ist jetzt perfekt wenn sie nicht
mehr läuft jetzt kommt die sahne
obendrauf
und da ist deswegen jetzt auch nicht
schlimm das jetzt hier so ein kleiner
krater training schwer da kann man jetzt
schon die sahne einführen wobei sah mich
da richtig aufpassen dass sie nicht
überschlagen wird sonst habt ihr nämlich
keine sahne mehr sondern butter und
durch die leistung der kitchenaid
passiert wirklich sehr schnell dass sie
überschlagen wird deswegen müsste da
immer ganz genau aufpassen und dann
sehen echt die einzelnen sekunden
das wird dann einfach vorsichtig darauf
verteilt das ist auch richtig sommer so
informativ so was richtig schmeckt schön
leicht erinnert auch an mein glas bisher
dieser rote in die kann ich euch noch in
der infobox verlinken
natürlich auch total lecker und da gebe
ich jetzt mein haar immer drauf und
digitalen digital ist sich übrigens so
eine exotische frucht und zwar hat die
so eine kleine schale außen und innen
kommt diese frucht auf die orange fahren
kann man ja abtrennen und das innere
erinnert so ein bisschen an der tomate
und diese frucht schmeckt schön
säuerlich und süß und ist so ein
richtiger ist eine richtige vitaminbombe
das können wir jetzt einfach alles so
schön obendrauf geben
die spitze
im prinzip können das jetzt so lassen
und so servieren natürlich nicht kurz
warten bis die früchte etwas angebaut
sind die schmecken aber auch ganz kalt
es ist toll ich werde es jetzt
allerdings noch etwas trocken etwa
schoko späne
zwar lässt und man nehme ich mir einfach
etwas tat bitter schokolade und da könnt
ihr mit etwas schokolade und einem
messer schoko späne machen und zwar lebt
ihr euch jetzt dieses messer drückt die
schokolade an euch dran
man könnte mit dem messer hier so kleine
röllchen ob sie so kleine schoko spiele
wie einfach und können sie hier oben
drauf geben
das finde ich mache das ganze nochmal
schön was mache ich jetzt somit dunkler
und weißer schokolade und zeige ich
echtes endergebnis und das war's dann
auch schon
eure torte ist fertig und im prinzip
geht es hier wirklich sehr einfach sehr
schnell und die torte sieht richtig
klasse und lecker aus also ich würde am
liebsten gleich reinbeißen
mein mann hat sag ich sollte aber erst
mal ein essen anschneiden
deswegen darf probieren nachlesen könnt
ihr das rezept auf www progen der
lisztschen welt.de den direkten link
setzt sich wie immer unten in die
infobox und falls ihr noch
weitere fragen dazu habt könnt ihr gerne
unter diesem video hier stellen
auf jeden fall ist ganz wichtig dass
jetzt auf papier pappe und ich hoffe
dass sie die kohlen mathe aber die
silikon matte hilft euch auf jeden fall
um den schönen kreis hinzubekommen
und ich würde sagen wir gehen jetzt
runter bevor die familie noch mehr
quatsch macht und sagen tschüss und
falls ich das video can't würden wir uns
freuen wenn ihr uns einen kommentar
lasst uns eine bewertung geht und das
video natürlich auch teil
die macht quatsch